octopath traveler was a pleasant
surprise when its debuted a few years
back its then new HD 2D engine was a
delight to behold and the gameplay Drew
inspiration from some of square annex's
most storied franchises a deep Final
Fantasy style class and customization
system mixed with the non-linear
exploration and story of The Saga series
with a dash of combat that took cues
from Bravely Default these are great
Inspirations to draw from but it
resulted in a game that while excellent
seemed to be struggling for a distinct
identity perhaps the developers
recognized this as well with octopath
traveler 2 Square Enix seems to be
trying to add new gameplay elements that
give the franchise a personality of its
own and for the most part it has
succeeded admirably
[Music]
the core of octopath traveler 2 is a
traditional turn-based jrpg with many of
the usual gameplay elements towns and
dungeons to explore objectives to
complete Etc where most grpgs present a
linear method of progression however
octopath traveler takes a very different
approach you begin the game by selecting
a main character from eight candidates
this character has their own unique
background story arc and goals and will
serve as a constant presence throughout
your play time after an introductory
Story chapter you are then free to
explore the world to your liking
eventually you'll meet the other seven
characters allowing you to bring them
into your party and follow their
storylines as well all culminating in a
finale that ties the individual story
threads together the focus on individual
character arcs rather than a huge
high-stakes threat for most of the
game's runtime is refreshing allowing
octopath traveler 2 to tell a variety of
intriguing stories That Vary wildly in
both tone and focus some of them are
comparatively weaker but others command
and hold your attention and keep you
eager for more agneus Star Struck search
for fame is notably Bland for instance
while tamanos's investigation into a
murder plot by a religious cult and
Thrones quest to kill the adoptive
parents who raised her are excellent
standouts my personal favorite questline
is the story of Oswald who I chose as my
starting character a tale of a scholar
who plans a Count of Monte Cristo style
prison escape and revenge after being
framed for the murder of his own family
by a scheming colleague as soon as you
finish the first part of a character's
story you're allowed to continue on to
the subsequent chapters as there are no
hard barriers to progressing how you
choose that doesn't mean you can stroll
anywhere in the world without a care
however some areas feature significantly
more dangerous foes than others and
trying to stumble through them with a
low-level party is quite an extreme risk
albeit one the game doesn't prevent you
from attempting if you feel confident in
your survival skills in fact going into
risky places can yield some major
rewards but there's nothing particularly
punishing about playing it safe either
octopath travel is lack of hand-holding
compared to many other jrpgs may be
off-putting at first it doesn't offer
much guidance aside from very basic
tutorials but the freedom it grants you
to explore and attempt challenges at the
Comfort level you choose is one of its
strongest points one of the most
interesting facets to exploration are
the path actions unique to each
character path actions are available
when interacting with the majority of
NPCs allowing you to engage with them in
a variety of ways acquiring items
learning abilities gaining extra
information needed to complete Main and
subquests and even recruiting them as
helpers in combat new to octopath
traveler 2 is a day and night cycle
which thankfully you can control at will
that changes which NPCs appear and what
path actions are available to you for
example Merchant particio can buy items
from NPCs during daytime and discounted
prices while at night he can hire
characters as assistants in combat there
is overlap in the functions of
characters path actions but judging
which is most useful in a given
situation adds a fun layer of strategy
not typically present in jrpg town
exploration then we come to combat which
is the most satisfying and engaging
element of octopath traveler 2 the
turn-based encounters build upon the
foundation set by the original
emphasizing the need to strategically
break down enemy defenses through the
use of specific skills and weapons
there's also a boost system that allows
you to significantly increase the
efficacy of characters actions by
consuming the Boost points that build up
slowly during each turn of combat the
unique nature of each character extends
to their performance in combat every
party member has several individual
skills and quirks that significantly
affect their specific actions and the
flow of combat as a whole Samurai warri
Hikari brings combat skills learned from
NPCs Into The Fray while Apothecary
Cassidy can mix items together to create
helpful or harmful concoctions perhaps
the most fun of these skills is that of
ochet a beast Woman Who can capture
enemies and cook them into health and
Status restoring meat or keep them to
use their skills in combat you don't
have to be content with just the default
skills of your characters either like
the original game you can assign
characters a sub job which will allow
them to learn active and passive skills
specific to each class as well as equip
a wider variety of Weaponry playing
around and discovering particularly
effective combinations of gear party
composition and skill sets is quite
enjoyable and rewarding with each new
skill unlock adding something new to
your overall repertoire and hidden job
classes and experience skills found over
the course of the game had even more
surprises and options a new element of
octopath traveler 2's battle
strategizing is latent Powers
character-specific limit break style
abilities that can dramatically affect
combat when used at the right time every
party member's latent ability is
different Oswald can transform
multi-target attacks into intensely
powerful single Target strikes Throne
can take an extra turn Hikari and a chat
get access to new attack skills and
teminos can break through defenses with
any attack using these skills in tandem
with a carefully crafted setup can
create delightfully devious outcomes
finding effective tools and setups can
allow you to get through combat
situations that typically you might be
horrendously under leveled for which
yields immense satisfaction when all
goes according to plan which sometimes
it doesn't but that's risk for you
octopath Traveler 2 isn't without some
quibbles and frustrations though every
character that joins you starts out at a
low level requiring a Time investment
before they get up to parity with the
rest of the party dungeon and field
exploration is very basic with little in
the way of puzzles or gimmicks to spice
up typical path following with only a
few side roads leading to treasure
chests taking you off the beaten path
sometimes you're overwhelmed with Choice
paralysis as to what to do next in the
various stories while at other times you
feel like all your potential next moves
are high-level Adventures that may put
you in way over your head the risk
reward system for certain path actions
is utterly nonsensical I won't get my
reputation in town tarnished for mugging
or picking fights with people but I will
if I fail to entice an NPC to join my
party these aren't huge Flaws by any
stretch but they are things that I hope
will be ironed out and spruced up in
potential future installments I'll to
path traveler 2 is an ideal sequel it
builds upon the foundations of the
original by improving on what worked
establishing common pillars of design
and gameplay combat mechanics path
actions freeform progress that will
hopefully carry forth through future
games it also iterates upon Concepts and
ideas borrowed from other jrpgs the day
night cycle and latent abilities that
enhance the overall experience octopath
traveler 2 is a delight from start to
finish and has left me looking forward
to seeing where this series will take
itself in the future
oh dear
[Music]
holy life
that's all
[Music]